[Música]
sabían ustedes que sólo el 0 a 0 0 0 0 1
por ciento de las personas en el mundo
asiste con los juegos olímpicos como
atletas
y sabían que ese número es aún más
exagerado en bolivia si países como eeuu
como china japón mandan 300 500 600
atletas bolivia manda 56 atletas en
promedio el año 92 en los juegos
olímpicos de barcelona
bolivia mandó a su equipo más grande 13
atletas
es un número bastante reducido pero por
qué por qué es tan difícil para un
atleta llegar a unos juegos olímpicos y
por qué es tan difícil para un atleta
boliviano sobre todo llegaron los juegos
olímpicos
hay muchos obstáculos muchas
dificultades en el camino evidentemente
pero muchas veces nuestro mayor
obstáculo somos nosotros mismos
yo logré llegar a unos buenos a unos
juegos olímpicos el año 2012 y a mis
segundos juegos olímpicos el año 2016
así que pertenezco ese pequeño
porcentaje
todos los cálculos evidentemente si tuve
muchos obstáculos pero bueno empecé a
nadar cuando tenía cinco años mis papás
me metieron a la piscina con una idea de
que aprendan a nadar de qué no me ahoga
y continuamos de vacaciones nunca con
una idea de que compita o sea campeona
ni mucho menos y peor yo yo no sabía que
podía haber un mundo tan grande en el
deporte porque en ese momento no había
tanta información como lo hay hoy en día
con las redes sociales simplemente bien
la televisión el cable el periódico así
que bueno como cualquier niño yo soñaba
con ser doctora ingeniera pero no
pensaba en ningún momento ser deportista
profesional
desde el año 2002 el año 2004
que me entero de la existencia de los
juegos olímpicos mis padres compraron un
periódico el día domingo y venía un
suplemento sobre los atletas bolivianos
que iban a asistir a los juegos
olímpicos de atenas
yo ahí abro los ojos y dijo bao hay más
allá en el deporte que simplemente
competir en bolivia o en cochabamba en
ese momento bien cochabamba y dijo yo
también quiero llegar unos juegos
olímpicos quiero salir en un suplemento
deportivo quiero llegar a ser grande
atleta y poder juntarme con todos estos
grandes del deporte entonces bueno en
teoría de objetivo trazado
pero tenía que saber cómo llegar a ese
objetivo así que me fui poniendo
pequeños objetivos para llegar a ese
objetivo tan grande que tenía
mi primer objetivo era poder hacer un
récord de categoría tenía 12 años en ese
momento fui ese año mi primera
competición internacional que era en
argentina
y cuando mi primera experiencia junto a
todas mis amigas mis amigas temblaban
sin necesidad de que se preocupan tanto
que está argentina está brasil está
colombia porque no te preocupa a ti
y escuchen esta expresión tan mediocre
vamos a perder de que se preocupan tanto
si está brasil si está argentina como
ustedes bolivianos piensan en ganar una
medalla simplemente disfruten el
campeonato pásenla bien y ya está
sorpresivamente bueno en este momento
nada mariposa y mariposa no puedes ver
en ningún lado tus competidores
simplemente es adelante gane cuatro
medallas de oro gane una medalla de
plata algo que ni yo imaginaba que podía
hacer
pero esta primera lección no la entendí
hasta años más tarde
puedo detenerme el objetivo mis
siguientes objetivos serán poder
clasificar una selección absoluta
todavía no muy pequeña pero no logré
logre clasificar a los juegos
bolivarianos a los juegos suramericanos
con tan solo 13 14 años y es bastante
bien empecé a entrenar doble turno por
la mañana es decir actores después del
cole digo bastante bien pero no fue
hasta el año 2008 que aprendí mi segunda
lección estaba primera en el ranking
boliviano se venían los juegos olímpicos
de beijing en dos este año 2008
pero aprendí que la vida no siempre es
justa no
estando primera el presidente de la
federación en ese momento toma la
decisión de mandar a otra nadadora para
representar a bolivia y yo me quedo sin
poder participar de los juegos olímpicos
pero dije no importa voy a seguir voy a
seguir porque no debe tener hasta poder
participar en unos juegos sólo incluso
entonces bueno sigue entrenando doble
turno hasta el año 2010 que bueno viene
un punto de inflexión a todo atleta
sobre todo en bolivia
que terminó el colegio y mis padres mi
diseñadora que va a hacer nuevas vídeos
del deporte te vas a morir de hambre y
dejar de nadar y tienes que dedicarte
estudiar después de una carrera estudio
bueno está bien es como una carrera pero
voy a seguir nadando porque es lo que me
encanta hacer así que me metí nada más y
nada menos a una carrera la más fácil de
todas me metí a medicina
pero bueno se complica un poquito más
todo pero yo seguí no empecé igual
entrenaba seis de la mañana pasaba
clases todo el día hasta las cinco de la
tarde a las seis se iba a nadar hasta
las 8 a las 8 am y marginadas hasta las
10 a las 10 volvió a mi casa estudiaba
hasta las 12 una levantaba a las 5 de la
mañana y así
bueno lleva este ritmo de vida hasta que
el año 2012 son los juegos olímpicos en
londres seguía primera en el ranking
esta vez las cosas fueron como tenían
que ser y me nominaron para representar
a bolivia los juegos olímpicos y estaba
de lo más contenta en los juegos ya
había logrado mi sueño pero volví y
todos los deportistas creo que somos así
vuelve y dije y ahora que quiero más no
puedo contentarme solo con esto pero si
sigo en bolivia no voy a poder lograr lo
que yo quiero que es clasificaron los
juegos no hay por invitación poder
representar mejor a bolivia
como si como si el cielo hubiera
escuchado mis períodos en este mismo año
me llama del comité olímpico y me dicen
que tenemos una beca para ti
y perfecto me voy y me dicen yo no quise
ni escuchar a dónde vas a ir no quieres
conversarlo con tus papás y dije no yo
me voy pero sólo dime dónde tengo que ir
y me dicen este entre francés puedes
escoger entre francia o españa y dije
está bien está bien ahora yo tenemos
dónde me voy pero es un hecho y me voy
los buenos de internet de los centros y
escojo españa porque era espectacular
entonces me fui a españa y estando ahí
dije ya no tengo todo tengo 5 piscinas
tengo en infraestructura que nunca he
tenido tengo un equipo
multidisciplinario que va a ayudarme a
conseguir mis objetivos lo voy a tener
que estudiar todo el día sino todo y
carme netamente esto para lograr los
objetivos
pero bueno estar en un centro alto
rendimiento' me enseñó tres cosas
me enseñó trabajo duro si yo creía en
bolivia que entrenaba duro porque hacía
doble sesión
siempre se puede entrenar más duro allá
empecé a entrenar aproximadamente 7 u 8
horas al día
entre la mañana natación por la tarde
natación gimnasio más cardio durante
todos los días de la semana incluso
domingos
me enseñó actitud esta actitud que yo
tenía mi primera competición de decir me
van a ganar porque son de brasil son de
argentina son de cualquier país x
me enseñó una competición en españa que
fue la primera en un campeonato nacional
bueno yo aquí estaba acostumbrada a
ganar los campeonatos nacionales dije
españa no conozco a ninguna velocista
que sea muy buena pues bueno una de gané
medalla de plata vivió bien y luego me
llegan los comentarios le acabas de
ganar a la queda recordista española le
acabas de ganar a la que fue finalista
en un europeo acabas de ganar a la que
fue equipo españa en los juegos
olímpicos la última versión y jugó ser
realmente si yo no me condicionó en
pensar con quien compito y magnífico en
mi competencia puedo hacerlo en las
cosas
y me enseñó una tercera lección
había un psicólogo en el centro que se
llama pez marín que decía hay una
diferencia entre implicancia y
compromiso
e implicarse que es por ejemplo la
gallina para hacer este plato se dejo
los huevos
pero el cerdo se dejó la vida para hacer
este desayuno qué quiere decir que no no
basta con ir a la piscina y hacer acto
de presencia o en cualquier cosa que
hagan tiene que poner el máximo esfuerzo
en todo lo que hagan cada día
en el momento para conseguir su objetivo
también dentro el deporte hay lo que es
el enteramente invisible que es dormir
bien comer bien cosas que yo no hacían
pedirme español entonces bueno logré al
finalizar la beca logré mi objetivo
logre clasificar a los juegos olímpicos
en río 2016 primera vez que un boliviano
clasificada de natación siempre fue con
invitación y bueno terminó el sueño
volví a bolivia
y viene la paz empieza a trabajar el
trabajo trabajando como entrenadora
continué con mis estudios y pensaba
bueno ya
ya está mi carrera ya logré todo lo que
quería lograr ahora en bolivia me va a
ser más difícil poder lograrlo no tengo
es infraestructura y no esté en el
centro tengo muchas cosas que hacer
pero sorpresivamente seguir mejorando y
mejore más en el tiempo que estuve en la
paz que en el tiempo que estuve en
barcelona porque porque las enseñanzas
que me dejó el kart las seguí trabajando
cada día el compromiso el trabajo duro y
la actitud del momento de competir
gané el año pasado en los juegos
bolivarianos la medalla de oro logrando
un récord bolivariano logré este año
tres medallas en los juegos
suramericanos en cochabamba y es ahí
cuando me di cuenta que no necesitaba
todo no necesitaba cinco piscinas no
necesitaba un equipo multidisciplinario
no necesitaba dedicarme únicamente a la
natación sino necesitaba
poder creer en mí mismo primero poder
creerme que soy capaz de ganar la
medalla y además de comprometerme a dar
el máximo en cada entrenamiento para
poder cumplir mis sueños
[Música]